and they found that those that use more
porn six months later than a year later
they did far worse on their academics so
that's the only longitudinal study I've
seen that could be carpal tunnel well I
didn't get into this because of religion
it's just a very strange story where
some guys about ten years ago start
showing up on my wife's forum which had
nothing to do with porn and they are
complaining and saying hey my penis
isn't working and I think is porn well
over the next few years these man
recovered from porn and do sexual
dysfunctions and eventually we started
to write about it because we felt
compelled because a lot of the men were
suicidal they thought they were broken
for life and yet they healed so we felt
like we needed to get the word out and
that's how all this started a lot of
people responded that the critics they
would say well you know what Gary Wilson
is just taking people who are chronic
abusers of pornography it's not
indicative of men who watched porn on
the internet the average male in 2017 so
his information is largely irrelevant
what would you say to those those
critics who who dabble in in pornography
and are there negative consequences if
any well first of all the only way to
assess if there's negative consequences
for you is to take a timeout and that is
to stop using porn for several months
and see if there's any changes there's
only been five studies which have had
non addicts for the most part stop using
porn and all of them found significant
changes some of them could think better
others found their relationships more
satisfying and others healed from sexual
problems so those are the only five that
have done it but I think you need to
step back and look at what's going on
more broadly you know think about
erectile dysfunction let's get on
something that's sort of solid okay I'd
like to think about it in the abstract
not so much at all at all and that is
the problem so if we look at erectile
dysfunction rates for men under 40
historically they've been between 2 and
3% up until about 2008 and then they
started to climb to the point where now
about seven studies between 2010 and
2007 teen found erectile dysfunction
rates in young man as high as 35% okay
so that's a jump of 1000% and there's
been no other variable that has changed
in the last 10 to 15 years that could
cause erectile dysfunction rate in young
men except our smartphone I was gonna
say it's not like their penis didn't
bring in a GMO corn are we sure about
that well the older men are also eating
GMO corn and their erectile dysfunction
rates haven't risen quite as much that's
one for you mister Wilson that's one for
you and what has changed is tube sites
and tube sites were invented in about
2007 and that was a real game-changer
where you now had free streaming porn
short little clips and you could put up
about 20 tabs and just click from tab to
tab while you're masturbating and if you
got bored you could click to a new genre
a new fetish and get your arousal up but
so this is what really changed the game
and we had older men men in their 50s
who said man I've been using porn
forever never had any problems but when
I started using tube sites about a year
later I couldn't get it up anymore
so is your problem exclusively with
online pornography sort of the social
media era porn or would you still say
that there are negative consequences to
the traditional you know Penthouse
magazine or pornography DVD well I think
you have to sort of separate the DVD so
if we look at something like a penthouse
or if you look at Playboy think about a
13 year old boy all I could do is look
at a picture of a naked woman what can
you think of maybe feeling or boobs up
who knows what but now a 13 year old
goes to a porn site and he sees the
hardest of the hardcore porn and he
looks at it masturbates to it every day
for about six years before he actually
kisses a girl so he's training a
sexuality in two ways the first way is
that's how I should do it Maran it
replaces this imagination to think the
next thing is I need everything
associated with my porn use to become
aroused and number one that's watching
other people do it or I need to click
from video to video
or I need to go through about 20 videos
and find the perfect shots to end on
right for in order to orgasm so that's
the game changer is it possible that
this generally would only affect
outliers people with addictive
personalities who would have the same
proclivities with any sort of chemical
or practice that is addictive there's no
such thing as the addictive personality
there are certain traits that lead to a
higher percentage of those people
becoming addicted for example depression
so depression people are depressed they
have a higher chance but the vast
majority of people who are depressed
never become truly addicted and what we
have now is something completely
different we have adolescents using porn
internet porn for nearly every
masturbation session if we had for
example adolescents starting age 12
drinking alcohol or smoking cigarettes
right at that age or using cocaine every
day there'd be a much higher percentage
who would end up being addicted to
having a hard time stopping so we're
having now something unique where
adolescents are using it most everyday
adolescent boys that are we've seen
studies now since our first interviews
there there's been a lot of discussion
particularly in the media about Facebook
social media and the same addictive
patterns being developed with that so is
it possible that it's just sort of the
medium itself as opposed to the content
well you can become addicted to
certainly the medium of the internet on
my side I have 220 internet addiction
brain studies and all of you show the
same brain changes as seen in substance
addicts so it is a real thing and also
on the my front page I have 34 brain
studies on porn users and all of them
are consistent with the addiction model
so even though you can become addicted
to Facebook think about a facebook what
is it words pictures you don't that's
something new why would you become
addicted to words and pictures well it's
the novelty it's the ability to
constantly switch from something new
something new something new and what
does novelty do well novelty actually
increases dopamine in the reward
Center so every little time you're
anticipating going to a new tweet or a
new Facebook picture you get a little
shot of dopamine if you do that hours
and hours you've trained your brain to
sort of want that to behave that and
other brain changes can in yes and I
would also say to be fair with Facebook
or Twitter social media a lot of times
these words or these pictures represent
you know a emotive responses right
whether it's oh your friends vacation or
relationship status it makes them feel
important I think that's what's attached
to it and then what could possibly
elicit a more powerful emotional
response in many people than then sex
right so I would seem like it's
significantly worse degree yeah I think
you know the difference between having a
mind-blowing orgasm and looking at a
picture of a sunset on a beach
so there is a difference in the brain
that differences in neural chemicals a
massive amount of dopamine a massive
amount of endorphins are released and
what is the number one purpose for every
organism to reproduce so you have huge
sections of the human brain devoted to
sexual arousal and reproduction and
those can be hijacked and molded
especially during adolescence through
watching hardcore streaming porn I guess
at this point there couldn't really be
long-term studies since like you said
two sites have been created in 2007
would there be any comparable long-term
studies that might show people the
consequences for example like
development of mental illness could be
ADHD could be depression do we know if
there's any kind of association there
you know there's very I can only think
of really one long-term study on porn
users it was actually twelve and
thirteen-year-olds and they're looking
at academics and they found that those
that use more porn six months later than
a year later they did far worse on their
academics so that's the only
longitudinal study I've seen that could
be carpal tunnel really well so for
these people watching at 2:00 a.m. if
they're looking for help if they feel as
though listen I'm kind of in a rut and
you know it's a catch-22 they need to
use pornography what what can they do
what resources do they have
well they can go to my site in it's a
non-commercial site and we have a list
of resources we have all sorts of
material they can then go to forums
where there's lots of guys mostly who
are trying to quit porn so there's been
a real explosion in forums where guys
are trying to quit and it's what's
interesting is these forums are largely
non-religious in fact one did a survey
is called no fat comm and 60% of the
users were atheists or agnostics so a
lot of men are starting to see that it's
having negative effects so there's lots
of resources and you can go to my side
and then I can Chanyeol Channel you into
all those resources so I think a lot of
people who aren't addicted or don't feel
they're addicted or seeing what it feels
like to take a break and since a lot of
them have grown up using even if they're
30 35 years old this is the first time
they've taken a break from porn for an
extended period and in that they're
discovering my goodness something is
going on here thank you so much mister
Wilson for coming back and it's been too
long we'll have to have you back
regularly because we get so much
feedback your brain on porn calm is a
site or the book like this video
subscribe by clicking the subscribe
button it's a kits aniseh circle now it
used to be a square which most buttons
aren't squares let's it's on a phone
there's square buttons on phones what
most buttons are circles you understand
what I'm talking about or watch the
recommended video which is popping up in
a box or subscribe at a lot or with
credit.com flash mug club join them on
clip so you can get the daily show and
that means that you are not beholden to
the YouTube censoring overlords let's be
honest you like being there where you
are under their thumb power bottom